>>> MILLIONS AROUND THE WORLD,
BRINGING THE SOUND OF THE
EMERALD ISLE TO PERFORMING ARTS
CENTERS NEAR YOU.
AND THIS SUMMER, YOUR GIRLS ARE
BACK WITH A BRAND NEW TOUR THAT
WILL LEAVE YOU SPEECHLESS.
IT'S CELTIC WOMAN.
♪♪♪
>> WITNESS THE CULTURAL EVENT
YOUR GOD MOTHER DESCRIBED AS
PERFECTION.
♪♪♪
♪ WAIT UNTIL THE SAILOR COMES ♪
>> THESE FLAT IRON MAIDENS BRING
YOU ONE THE SEXUAL EYE CONTENT
JOURNEY OF A LIFETIME.
>> WE LOVE IT.
THE GIRLS DOING THE SONG, IF I
HAD TO DESCRIBE IT IN ONE WORD,
I WOULD SAY IRELAND.
>> ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS AND THE
MUSIC WASN'T BAD EITHER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU, I
THOUGHT I HAD PURCHASED TICKETS
TO A BOSTON CELTICS GAME.
I WAS VERY CONFUSED FOR THE
FIRST COUPLE MINUTES BUT THEY
WERE TWIRLING.
I GOT TO SAY I LOVED THAT.
>> WITNESS IRISH CULTURE THE WAY
IT WAS MEANT TO BE ENJOYED, IN
OHIO.
>> TOP OF THE EVENING TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
I'M SAOIRSE.
>> I'M MARY.
>> AND I'M FAITH.
>> AND WE ARE CELTIC WOMEN.
IF YOU LIKE RIVER DANCE BUT WISH
THEY COULD MOVE THEIR ARMS,
YOU'LL LOVE US.
>> CAN EIGHT DEEP-CUT GAELIC
BATTLE SONGS.
♪♪♪
>> SOME LOOSELY AUTHENTIC
ORIGINALS.
♪ GO DOWN TO THE CASTLE, WE'LL
SEE YOU AT THE CASTLE ♪
>> AND A RANDOM ASSORTMENT OF
NOT GAELIC SONGS THAT THE
AUDIENCE JUST KIND OF WANTS TO
HEAR.
♪ SWEET HOME ALABAMA LORD I'M
COMING HOME TO YOU ♪
>> GENUINELY THE MOST FUN I'VE
EVER HAD IN MY LIFE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT SAYS
ABOUT ME, BUT IT'S TRUE.
>> WELL, IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
THEY SANG THE SAME SONG
20 TIMES.
YOU KNOW IT WAS A GREAT SONG.
>> HORNY PONYTAIL DUDES.
WHO PLAYS 100 GIANT DRUMS.
AND WHO COULD FORGET THIS CHICK?
KIND OF A RUNNING VIOLIN GIRL.
LOOK AT HER GO!
SHE'S DOING IT.
YOU LOVE IT!
ONE TINY ISLAND.
BIG SOUND.
FOUR IRISH ELSAS.
TAKE YOUR GRANDMA AND WATCH THE
POPULAR GIRLS FROM YOUR HIGH
SCHOOL GET ABSOLUTELY RAILED BY
THE IDEA OF IRELAND.
♪ I HEAR THE DRUMS ♪
♪ I SIT ON THE BAGPIPES AND GIVE
IT A BLOW ♪
♪♪♪
>> CELTIC WOMAN, THE LION KING.
TICKETS NOT AVAILABLE ONLINE.
YOU HAVE TO COME.
[ APPLAUSE ]